damn some it's a great company but it's
a competitive Apple and it's not fair
because we have a trade deal with Korea
we made a great great deal in South
Korea but we have to treat Apple on a
somewhat similar basis as we treat
Samsung now with all of that being said
we're doing very nicely with China but I
like it the way it is now because we're
taking in billions and billions of
dollars that we're giving some of that
money to farmers and others but we are
looking at Apple what I wanted apples
I said someday we're gonna see Apple
building plants in our country not in
China and that's what's happening
it's all happening it's all the American
dream our country has never done better
it's doing better than it's ever done
unemployment the lowest levels numbers
just came out today African American
Hispanic American Asian American the
lowest they've ever had in the history
of our country so I can tell you this
China would much rather make a trade
deal that I was I don't think they're
stepping up to the level that I want I
spoke earlier today with mister
here's what I said here's what I say
what do you know I put in tariffs
everyone said ology to make it in
billions hundreds of billions of dollars
we all be taken in and everybody said oh
that's gonna be bad for the economy well
as you just heard from Tim Cook we have
the strongest economy by far in the
world and we'll take it in billions and
billions of dollars so we'll see what
happens we are dealing with China have a
great relationship with President Xi
they're a great country but we're a
greater country than China if I didn't
win right now China would be a bigger
economy than the United States
cuz i won we picked up reported in your
network eleven trillion dollars in worth
of value
and China's lost probably twenty five
trillion dollars we are much bigger than
China right now and we're going to keep
it that way